[Music]
right as we continue our coverage of
Attorney General bars commitment to
review all the FBI DOJ conduct in the
Russia probe we always make the
distinction not rank and file not at all
I have an FBI flag pin here in
solidarity with the 99.9% it is the
world's premier law enforcement agency
by far
joining us now Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Senator Lindsey
Graham senator I went through it all you
heard the Attorney General today we've
already known a lot of this but now it's
all coming out right well so you know
what did the Attorney General to say say
today he's gonna look at how this got
started you know it's there's no doubt
they were spying on Trump's people in
campaign the question was was it lawful
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act allows you to follow around people
you think are working with a foreign
government counterintelligence
investigation by very definition is
surveilling people that you think are
spying so the question was it was it
lawful well was it no well we'll see I
tell you this if the warrant was based
on the dossier that wasn't lawful and I
don't know why they did not tell Trump
about people on his campaign work
senator Russia if they really believe
that I actually read something that I
know there's something that exists it's
called the Grassley Graham memo yeah it
might be somebody you know in there in
that the bulk of information for the
FISA application was in fact Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for Russian
dossier when they presented it to the
FISA Court they never told the court she
paid for it they never told the court it
was unverified and by the way we now
know unverifiable because steel doesn't
stand by his own dossier and so they
never verified it and they denied Carter
pages constitutional rights by
committing a fraud on the court is there
anything wrong with what I just said
well you know what you said and what we
can prove are two different things I
believe that the dossier is unverified
to this day I have a reason to believe
it was the main reason the warrant was
issued I believe the court was never
told it was paid for about political
party and that the
I'm prepared it hated Trump I believe
that the counterintelligence
investigation is questionable at best
and I still don't know why they would
not tell Trump hey a couple of people in
your campaign may be working with the
Russians like they told Feinstein about
somebody on hurt her off in her office
working with the Chinese none of this
adds up bars gonna look at it I'm gonna
look at it Horowitz is gonna look at it
can I make one point about obstruction
of justice yeah the Muller team charged
a lot of people with crimes he has the
ability to charge people the crimes he
chose not to charge Trump for a reason
he didn't think he could prove a turn a
crime so Muller charges a bunch of
people with crimes he gets some
convictions he chose not to charge
President Trump with obstruction for a
reason not enough evidence the the
general counsel mean the top lawyer at
the FBI under Comey believed Hillary
should have been indicted I think that
investigation needs to begin anew now
that we know the players their political
biases and also the fact that it's real
we know there were classified materials
we know it's illegal and then you want a
different Democrats care about
obstruction look at Hillary's email
server subpoenaed emails here's the
thing though it can't be verified as a
matter of fact most of it's been
debunked in terms of the dossier and the
reason it can't be verified is because
the author he won't even stand by his
own dossier when he was put under oath
in an interrogatory and Great Britain so
we know that was false and called me in
a sign the first warrant application in
October 2016
went to Trump Tower in January 2017 then
president-elect Trump and said it's
verified it's not verified but salacious
so did call me lie to Trump then or did
he lie on the FISA application but he
lied on one of those occasions well the
point is that we're going to look at all
this and put it on the record for
history sake and try to tour other
people from doing this so if in fact the
DA say is unverified to this state which
I believe how could you use it to get a
warrant against an American citizen four
times if you really
hold trump here it is we can't verify it
why would you use the same document
before a court to say we believe it's
accurate enough to get a warrant if you
really believe that Trump's campaign was
being infiltrated by Russians why didn't
you tell him so he could do something
about it and how could Clinton get away
with all of this and not have anything
no charges at all when the average
person would probably be in jail now I
think it has a lot to do about a
political bias Andrew became no dossier
no FISA warrant their words not mine
last thing yeah huge day the one man
that was on the world stage for many
years alone identifying evil in our time
was the Churchillian figure of Prime
Minister Netanyahu he won a big victory
yesterday he's behind Churchill now he's
a legend and great outcome for the
United States Bibi is the most reliable
partner for the United States in the
world a strong man in a tough
neighborhood I'm glad he won god bless
him look forward to working with him and
and now with Trump as the biggest
supporter of Israel in modern times
Jerusalem to go on world's a safer place
they had a bad day for the Ayatollah bad
day for the Ayatollah I'm so sad to hear
that